all right dexter is back there's dexter
new blood a new season of dexter what is
an intro of a new video without some
triple speak going on now a couple
things right out the gate i'm gonna get
spoilerish you know i get spoilerish
when i talk about episodes of shows and
so here we are take heart knowing it's
just spoilers for the first episode it's
not like i'm going too deep because i
can't but i will get spoilerish for the
show the series dexter before this new
season of dexter also so you know just
know that i'm actually filming this
after i'm editing because i just
realized like i just jumped into talking
about this without actually telling you
what the show dexter was even about i
just kind of assumed like obviously you
know dexter but if you were six when
dexter wrapped you're 16 in driving now
so i shouldn't assume that you know what
the show dexter was in short the show
dexter was about a guy named dexter
morgan who was a blood spatter expert
for miami metro pd
but also he was a serial killer but the
code taught to him by his adoptive
father who also was a cop was you only
kill people who are murderers who slip
through the cracks you know kill [ __ ]
bags don't kill innocent people and now
we revisit dexter 10 years later alright
now you know so if you don't remember
dexter was
in my opinion one of the best shows
airing like in its peak in its prime
otherwise known as the first four
seasons of dexter like i own the first
four seasons of dexter on blu-ray and i
own none of the others because to me
that is the series that's i think it's a
fine ending you know bloody bathtub and
babies sitting there it's like yeah
there you go dexter it's what your dark
passenger brought in life the end it's a
fine enough ending better than the
ending we actually got for the show
dexter kind of like how avengers
infinity war i think is also a fine
ending snap half of everyone's vaporizer
you go heroes that's why you don't try
don't try to help go play with your toys
bad guys win but regardless of what my
dark passenger may or may not have
wanted for the show we have a new season
of dexter by showrunner clyde phillips
if you didn't know clyde phillips was
the showrunner for the first four
seasons of dexter when he left you
completely felt it but now show runner
clyde phillips and michael c hall have
joined forces to bring a new season of
the show dexter which dexter is in the
place we saw him at the end of dexter
season and the series finale of dexter
canonically they kept it it's not like
they wiped away the final season like a
fans didn't like it okay it didn't
happen also deborah's dead
which was dumb but this time around
she's the hairy character you know
instead of harry morgan instead of james
rimar being there to talk to dexter in
his imagination it's deb debra's there
to talk in dexter's ear making sure he
has his routine down just like dude just
keep your head down don't get involved
in any of the drama just get through the
day now the premiere of dexter new blood
had a job to do and i felt it did it
really well which was get you
reacquainted with dexter morgan this
show is actually this premiere was
described to me by a buddy i think very
aptly he said it was like seeing an old
friend you haven't seen in a long time
so in that you have to reacquaint people
with dexter illustrate that he's in a
different place in his life
but i mean come on why are we clocking
in we want to see him kill a person
right i don't know i do and i felt they
did it really well too it's a very
somber tone not just because of the
surrounding area and the fact that
everything's very cold very small town
everyone knows him his name is uh jim
lindsey it's the aliens he's going under
which undoubtedly is a tip a nod you
know tip of the hat to jeff lindsay who
writes the dexter books but it's not
just the location that feels different
it makes it very somber it's the fact
that it hit me
earlyish i was like why does this feel
oh there's no dark passenger when people
are talking to him and he has that long
pause it's not filled with this dark
passenger this inner monologue that the
audience can hear where he makes a
snarky comment that just kind of cracks
you up but it's still filmed the same
it's filmed in a way where it's like
there was supposed to be a dark
passenger monologue filling it up but
it's just filled with silence it makes
it very noticeable that he's missing
something in his life and it makes it
very apparent that the life he's living
this is like camouflage on top of
camouflage now the dark passenger
awakens of course because in this town
in the middle of nowhere i guess a bunch
of rich people come in to
hunt ski ice fish whatever rich people
do and of course you know there's got to
be some douche elements that dexter
needs to take out because they get high
and drunk and and kill really majestic
creatures that dexter has learned to
love and be responsible for deaths and
hide it and of course that's dexter's
like
that's my thing set up the kill room and
all right we're going to take this guy
out now when the dark passengers awaken
you here that whole like it's been a
while that's when i was like oh
i haven't seen you know what man how you
been i was live now the biggest part of
this whole thing is that he gets visited
by this young dude who is
harrison he's harrison morgan his son
but we don't know why he's here and we
don't know what that's gonna bring to
dexter's life what complications because
he's got this really nice really sweet
really pretty girlfriend i mean he's
gonna be like by the way
um surprise
i'm a dad a teenager you didn't know
that did you i mean he can't right that
would that would just lead her she's a
cop that would lead her down the path of
like okay where's this guy come from so
you have a couple things that work now
the dark passengers awakened there's a
douche element in here that dexter's
gonna kill it's how many people is he
gonna kill though like did he just hit
the jackpot of like yeah in this small
town there's as many people to kill per
season
as there was in miami man i mean that's
that's a lucky stroke for him not saying
people don't get lucky there are people
out there that invested in bitcoin when
bitcoin was a buck some people just get
lucky but you also have harrison back
and why is he back is harrison just
trying to connect with his father or is
harrison like oh by the way i have
serial killer tendencies and can you
help me out with that if that's the case
is dexter going to help him in the way
harry helped him which is like okay
here's how you kill people and get away
with it but live by the code kill shitty
people and the world's not gonna shed a
tear or his dexter gonna be like
being a killer
objectively didn't lead to a good life
for me good people died now i'm cold all
the time so let's try to overcome that
and find a routine that gets us past
these serial killer tendencies since the
pilot episode showed that dexter could
do that now he can teach harrison there
are a hundred questions i'm asking
myself but the best thing is i'm asking
those questions i'm interested enough
engaged enough to ask those questions
worst case scenario would be i see the
pilot episode of dexter new blood and
i'm like
don't care well that's not where i am
i'm excited to see where showrunner
clyde phillips and michael c hall
bring dexter's conclusion something that
i didn't get to see before unless you
count dexter's conclusion uh being rita
laying in a bloody bathtub which i have
been doing for the past 10 years now i
don't know if i'm gonna do weekly videos
on dexter new blood i just i don't know
i make no promises well see i don't plan
that far ahead that's a few days from
now happiness is here in the present all
right so the season premiere of dexter
new blood it's on showtime right now
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
it's like a
just hit my light calm the arms down
jeremy here behind my back how about
that
it's really hard for me to talk with i
don't even have my thoughts in order i
can't do that
well now we know i need the hands to
even get thoughts in order
it is me